>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Emilio Garcia-Ruiz: Without
further adieu, Alejandro Danois.
[ Applause ]
>> Alejandro Danois:
Thank you, Emilio,
for that awesome introduction.
That gentleman's name was
Gary D Howard who was working
at the Milwaukee Journal
Sentinel at the time.
And that was a really pivotal moment
for me when I ran down the escalator
to talk to him, because he asked
me, can you do that every time?
And I said, does a bear
defecate in the woods?
Yes, I can.
So that's awesome.
I didn't know anyone else knew that
story, that he shared that story.
So Emilio, thanks for bringing
back some awesome memories.
The Boys of Dunbar was a
10-year passion project for me.
I'll give you a little
bit of background of,
you know, how this thing started.
Initially, it was a magazine
story idea that I sent
to a very prominent magazine.
I sent a two to three
paragraph pitch to a gentleman,
and he got back to me and
said, I really like this,
but we're not going to use it,
because I think you have
something so much bigger here.
And he put me in touch with
some people who were veterans
of the publishing industry.
And they said, wow, this
is a wonderful idea,
are you up to taking a two to
three paragraph magazine proposal
and turning it into an
80-page book proposal?
And so from there, was
just off and running.
The seeds of this story were
planted way back in 1982 for me.
And this was around the time
that this team was accomplishing
some magnificent things
on the basketball court.
I grew up in Brooklyn, New York,
and there was a basketball court
directly behind my building.
And we were basketball
enthusiasts, junkies, morons,
whatever you want to call it.
We were out there every day.
If it was snowing, we
were shoveling snow.
We not only played but
we debated and we argued,
everything that's basketball
related.
And for people in here that
are familiar with folks
from New York City, we were
loud, we were arrogant,
and we thought we knew everything.
So we're 12 years old, and we're
talking about our favorite players
from New York, and why New
York is the king of basketball.
So we're talking about Bernard
King for the New York Knicks
who was our favorite
player at the time.
We're talking about Julius
Erving, the Great Doctor Jay was
from Long Island, who we loved.
Tiny Archibald, the only player
to ever lead the NBA in assists
and scoring in the same year.
Guys by the name of World be Free,
Vinnie the Microwave Johnson.
We're even going back to Bob Cousy,
the Great Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
If you were lucky enough,
you saw him wondering the
halls, he's here today.
And we're talking about
all these players,
and they are older neighborhood
superheroes that we're watching
and we're seeing play in these
great playground tournaments.
There was a guy in
high school by the name
of Chris Mullen, who was awesome.
We loved Chris Mullen.
Our personal hero was a guy by the
name of Duane the Pearl Washington,
who was significant in
turning the Big East Conference
in Syracuse University basketball
into the phenomenon
that it later became.
There was a guy by the
name of Walter Berry,
who went on to become the National
Player of the Year at St. John's,
leading them to the Final Four.
These were guys we saw around
the neighborhood and playing.
And there were other guys our
own age who we're hearing about.
There was a guy by the
name of Kenny Anderson,
and we called him Kenny the Kid,
or Kenny Ice, who was tearing
up the youth playground tournaments.
There was a guy by the name of Malik
Sealy, the great late Malik Sealy.
And all of these other players.
We heard about these brothers
in Coney Island called the Marbury
Brothers, Norman and Jou-Jou,
and a bunch of other ones.
And little did we know that their
younger brother, Stephon Marbury,
would go on to surpass them all.
And so we're having
this conversation
about how great New York is, and
there's an older gentleman who lives
in my building, and he was
probably in his young 20s.
He was an excellent
playground basketball player
and we used to go watch him play.
And he said, yeah, New York's
the king of basketball,
but the greatest team I ever
saw was a high school team
from Baltimore called Dunbar.
And so we're watching the
Philadelphia 76ers and Doctor Jay
and Larry Bird with the Celtics
and Magic Johnson with the Lakers.
And we said, wait a minute,
the greatest team you ever saw is
a high school team from Baltimore?
And he goes on to explain, every
player on the bench is going
to play Division I basketball.
They have the number one high
school player in the country
by the name of Reggie Williams.
Wait till you get a chance
to see him in college.
He's six foot seven.
He can play every position
on the floor.
He can block shots.
He can rebound.
He can shoot jump shots.
He can pass.
He's marvelous.
He's unbelievable.
But the crazy thing is, he's
not even the best player
on his own team.
So we're scratching our
head and saying, okay,
the number one high school player
in the country is not even the best
player on his own team, yeah, right.
So who is the best player?
And he said, you're not
going to believe me.
Come on, man, who is
the best player?
He says, all right, the best
player is a five-foot midget,
and his name is Muggsy.
He called him Muggsy.
And we thought he was lying.
We thought he was playing with us.
A couple of years later,
I'm watching this innovative
cable network with the idea
of 24-hour sports programming
called ESPN.
And I'm watching a Wake Forest
University basketball game,
and I see a 5'3 athletic marvel
unlike anything I've ever seen
before by the name of Muggsy Bogues.
And I screamed to no one in
particular, that's Muggsy.
And so I was in prep school
in Massachusetts at the time.
And there was a player by
the name of Reggie Lewis
at Northeastern University, who
was phenomenal, unbelievable,
tearing up the college
basketball scene.
And I heard that he couldn't even
start for his own high school team.
So I did a little digging,
a little bit of research,
and found out that he
attended Dunbar High School
with this guy named Muggsy Bogues.
And so the light bulb went on and
I started to think about this team.
Reggie Williams and David Wingate
were at Georgetown University
at the time, at the apex of the
phenomenon known as Hoya Paranoia.
They delivered John Thompson's
only national championship.
And Reggie Williams as a
freshman at Georgetown,
was the most valuable player,
the most outstanding player
in the Final Four when they defeated
an incredibly talented Phi Slama
Jama team from the University of
Houston that featured future Hall
of Famers Hakeem Olajuwon, Clyde
Drexler, and a number of others.
Reggie had 19 points and seven
rebounds in the final game.
And to think that the year before,
this guy was in high school,
just boggles the mind and tells
you how exceptional he was.
And so this idea had been
marinating for a while,
and then we fast-forward
to me merging my passion
for the written word with
sports, and deciding,
I'm going to tell this story.
And we rewind to the magazine
pitch, to stretching it
out to become a book proposal.
And the long story short version is,
spending 10 years putting
this story together.
And I initially thought
I was embarking
on a basketball story, right.
Story of perhaps the greatest high
school basketball team of all time.
This is the story that
I'm going to tell.
And so I buried myself
in the archive rooms
at the Enoch Pratt main library
in Baltimore on Cathedral Street.
And I said, I have to find
out what was going on.
I have to look at these games.
I had to see who did what.
Put that together.
But I also said, I need to read the
newspaper from front to back to find
out what was going on at the time.
And so it wasn't until I actually
started reading what was going
on in the city and around
the country that I realized,
this is a basketball story that's
not even about basketball at all.
And so we look at what was
going on in the early 1980s
in Baltimore at the time.
And we found this once proud
city really struggling.
And there were some forces
that were really laying siege
to this once proud community.
Through the head coach Bob
Wade, we kind of get the story
of his parents being part of
this great northern migration.
They were from a very
small town called Dillwyn,
Virginia, down South.
And as we know, the agrarian
economy had ground to a halt.
And a lot of African-American
people were in search
of the so-called promised land.
And Bob Wade's parents were
emblematic of the people
who left the tobacco fields and
the cotton fields down South
in search of the promised land.
And Baltimore happened to be
one of those promised lands.
Because due to the World War II
economy, they had iron foundries
and steel mills, the great Bethlehem
Steel complex, car factories.
They were hiring people
for three shifts a day.
You didn't have to have
a high level of education
in order to get a job there.
And the economic prospects were so
much better in cities like Baltimore
and other cities, that
people migrated to.
So people were able to
get a decent union wage.
And they were able
to purchase homes.
And they used to scrub those marble
steps in front of those row homes
in East Baltimore with pride.
And they dreamed of sending
their kids on to college
and having a better life
for them then they had.
And so when we fast-forward now
to the early 1980s in Baltimore,
where the book takes place,
we find that there is the
loss of that union wage.
The way that people were
accustomed to making a living
and dreaming was no
longer a reality.
And so Bethlehem Steel, as
I found out as I was going
through the newspaper
archives of the Baltimore Sun
and the Baltimore News American,
were laying people off
at an astounding rate.
The General Motors plant
was laying off people.
The iron foundries, the steel
mills, the jobs disappeared,
because the economy changed.
And within that, we also had the
onset of the plague of crack cocaine
at the same time, which
ravaged the community.
Baltimore had long been a town that
was dominated by the heroin trade,
and the drug business was
always big in Baltimore.
But there was a very big
shift in the early '80s.
There was a federal drug
task force that took out all
of the big-time kingpins
around the heroin trade.
These guys were older businessmen.
They were very smart.
They kept it away from
schools, from the outdoors.
The inventories were regulated.
They ran it like a real business.
When those guys got taken away,
some gentlemen filled the vacuum.
And they realize that
there were loopholes
in the city's juvenile
justice system.
And so what happened was, they
said, if an adult gets caught
with my stuff, I've got to pay
lawyer fees, they're going to go
to jail for 10 to 15 years.
If a kid is younger than 18 and
he's caught selling my stuff,
he's going to go to a
juvenile detention facility,
and the next day he's going to
be home with mom and grandma.
So they started recruiting
teenagers into these drug armies.
They created this new business model
called the Open Air Drug Market,
which ran 24 hours
a day for 20 years.
And so when you have this army of
undisciplined young people fighting
over this business where the
profit margins are so astounding,
you have teenagers with a stupefying
amount of semiautomatic weapons,
random gunfire, a destruction
of the community.
And all of this stuff
happens around the time
with this great high school
basketball team comes together.
You have the head coach Bob Wade,
who was a product of
Dunbar High School.
He grew up in East Baltimore.
He himself was a product
of a single-parent home.
And so he went on to get a college
scholarship to play football.
Played in the National Football
League for the Washington Redskins,
the Baltimore Colts,
the Denver Broncos,
and the Pittsburgh Steelers.
But he was also cognizant
of the fact
that he had some wonderful mentors
and role models who helped him.
And while he was in the
National Football League,
he came back every summer to work
on his teaching certification.
And his goal was to make an impact
on the young lives of athletes
in the same way that his
role models did for him.
He was the valedictorian of
his graduating class at Dunbar.
His mother worked in a textile mill.
And she always told
him, get your education,
be serious about your degree,
I don't want you working
in a textile factory like me.
And he took that responsibility
seriously.
And so when he's the head coach at
Dunbar, and this team comes along,
he is adamant that they
are going to take care
of your academic responsibilities.
And so he ran the program very much
like you see the elite
college programs run today.
At the end of school,
practice did not start at 3:30,
study hall started at 3:30.
He recruited teachers and
professionals from the community
to serve as mentors and tutors.
They would work with the kids around
their schedules, time management,
okay, you have a test coming
up on Tuesday, you have a quiz
in this class on Wednesday, you
have a paper due next Monday.
And they helped them really
get an understanding of how
to handle the academic rigor that
they were going to need to abide
by when they got to college if
they were going to stay eligible.
So sometimes practice didn't
start till 5:30, 6:00 at night,
until the last textbook got closed.
And this was a time where
there weren't distinctions
on how long you could
run a practice.
And so his practices were brutal.
They practiced holding bricks,
because he could not
afford a fancy weight room.
And we talk about the economics
of what was going on at the time
in the community, he would drive
around to these dilapidated
buildings and just pick
up these bricks and
wrap them in duct tape.
And the guys would actually
practice their drills sometimes
with bricks in their hand.
Sometimes a basketball
never got bounced
in a three-to-four-hour practice.
They worked with sandbags, with
backpacks filled with sand,
that they ran around
with on their back.
And the philosophy behind
that was, no team will be
in better condition then we are.
So when you look at
Wade's story, and again,
his family being emblematic of
that great northern migration,
now we look at this
collection of talent
that we see on the basketball court.
We mentioned Muggsy Bogues, the
five foot three athletic marvel
who could dominate a game
without scoring a point.
I thought I knew everything there
was to know about basketball,
and when I saw him play, I did not
realize that that was possible.
We have already seen a
reasonable facsimile of the person
that everyone thinks is the
greatest basketball player ever
in Michael Jordan.
I think it's safe to say that
Kobe Bryant came pretty close
to being a reasonable
facsimile of Michael Jordan.
I believe we will see 10 more
Michael Jordans before we see
another Muggsy Bogues.
Because his talent was so rare.
He was a one-man fast-break
defensive dynamo pressing machine
who could alter the
landscape of a game simply
with his leadership
in defensive pressure.
We talked about Reggie Williams,
the number one high school player
in the country, who won the
National Championship at Georgetown.
David Wingate, whose
mother was paralyzed
and had never seen him
play a game of basketball
until his final high
school game championship
in the Baltimore Civic Center.
8500 people, standing-room only.
He says he wanted to
go to the University
of Maryland, that was his dream.
And when John Thompson walked into
his living room, his mother said,
you are going to play for this man.
She knew nothing about basketball,
Patrick Ewing, Georgetown,
you're going to play for this man.
Reggie Lewis did not start for
the Dunbar Poets, and he goes on,
let's think about this, to
become the best NBA player
out of all of them.
He supplants Larry Bird, Hall of
Famer Larry Bird, as the captain
of this legendary Boston
Celtics franchise.
And unfortunately, passes away at
the age of 28 due to a heart defect.
His mother had a heart
attack when she was 15.
His brother was born with
a small hole in his heart,
had multiple open-heart surgeries.
There was a medical history of
heart problems in his family.
And very sad that Reggie
passes away at the age of 28.
But he did not start for
this high school team.
And so to think about what he
blossomed into and what he became,
the lazy narrative is that, man,
this guy wasn't even good enough
to start for his own
high school team.
That's not true.
Bob Wade said he thought
about starting him,
but there was the starting
center by the name of Tim Dawson,
who went on to become the
Atlantic 10 Rookie of the Year
at George Washington University.
He later transferred to
finish his college career
at the University of Miami.
Tim Dawson right now is probably the
most successful out of all of them.
He went on to get a PhD and
was a principal at a number
of different school
systems in Florida
and Baltimore and in Maryland.
And Tim Dawson was a very strong
physical basketball player.
And he could block shots,
could jump out the rim.
And when he slam dunked the ball,
he was trying to rip the rim down.
So think about this from a
psychological perspective.
You're getting your brains
beat in by 40 points.
Tim Dawson is dunking all over you,
grabbing every rebound,
blocking every shot.
When he goes to the bench, the
other team takes a sigh of relief,
and says, whoo, now we got a chance.
I comes Reggie Lewis,
and they get better.
Unbelievable.
It speaks to Bob Wade's acumen
and the psychology to be able
to convince a player of that talent
to come off the bench and not start.
And so this team was not a team that
was recruited by some super scout.
When we see these great prep
teams today like Oak Hill Academy,
like Monteverdi Academy in Florida,
they're not only recruited from all
over the country, they're
recruited from all over the globe.
Ben Simmons, the most recent
number one pick in the NBA draft.
Phenomenal talent.
Went to Monteverdi.
He's from Australia.
The shooting guard on his Monteverdi
team was from Louisville, Kentucky.
The point guard was from Florida.
We'll never see a team like
this of young men that grew
up with each other, playing in
the back alleys on milk crates
when the older guys would
shoo them off the courts.
They ate at the same dinner tables.
They competed with and
against one another
at the neighborhood
recreation centers.
They were in the Dunbar
gym as little children.
They knew all the cheers.
They knew all of the fight songs.
And they were just little
kids excited to be part
of this great institution,
because Dunbar,
like the very strong
African-American churches
in Baltimore that played such a
pivotal role in the community,
Dunbar was similar to those
other revered institutions.
So Muggsy and Reggie
Williams were the best
of friends from a very early age.
They were nicknamed Mutt and Jeff.
Because out of a 24-hour day,
they spent 16 of them together.
Reggie was tall and skinny.
Muggsy was short and squat.
But you always found them together.
No one knew what type
of potential they had.
They were riding their
rollerskates together.
They were playing baseball together.
They were playing football together.
They were at the local recreation
center, playing checkers and dancing
and listening to music, doing
arts and crafts activities.
Before they even showed a
hint of athletic potential,
these guys were cohesive.
And when people saw the embryonic
relationship that they had
on a basketball court, Muggsy could
come, look away from the basket,
throw an underhand alley-oop.
Everybody would say, what
in the world did he just do?
Reggie would come flying
out of nowhere,
grab it, slam it through the rim.
People would run out of the stands.
They'd never seen anything
like that before.
And they could do that
and communicate
with one another without
saying a word.
Because from the age of five,
six, and seven years old,
they had this relationship.
So it really is a basketball
story that's not about basketball.
It's about community.
It's about love.
It's about mentorship.
It's about family.
And it really is about how this team
that created this majestic sense
of artwork through this
sport of basketball
on a basketball court gave
a struggling community hope.
Because people were being laid off.
You had the drugs really
decimating the community.
And for those two hours that
you were in that Dunbar gym,
it was the cheapest entertainment
ticket in town, you could forget
that you didn't know how you
were going to pay the rent.
You could forget that
the Baltimore gas
and electric bill had
a turnoff notice.
You could forget what drugs
were doing to the family.
You could forget that you didn't
have any food in the fridge
and you didn't know how you
were going to get groceries.
And for those two hours,
you were part of a show,
and they made you smile, and
they made you feel magnificent,
and they gave you hope that
something good could happen.
So I know we only have a few
minutes left, and I did want
to open the floor up
to some questions.
So how does it work?
We go back to a microphone
and ask a question?
[ Silence ]
>> Excellent presentation.
Really enjoyed it.
>> Thank you.
>> Did any of the players
come back to Baltimore to try
and make it a better place
after their basketball career?
>> Well, the funny thing is
when you look at the trajectory
of these guys, even
the guys that went
on to the NBA, they became coaches.
And so maybe not necessarily
coming back to Baltimore.
There actually is the
young men considered one
of the greatest coaches in the
country right now in the prep level,
probably the best coach in
the region, is a young man
by the name of Herman Tree Harried.
He was nicknamed Helicopter,
for folks that are fans
of Syracuse University teams, with
Derek Coleman and Pearl Washington
and Rony Seikaly and those guys.
He came back and he's the
coach at Lake Clifton now.
And has coached some
excellent teams.
Muggsy went on to become
the head coach
of the Charlotte Sting in the WNBA.
He coached at United Faith
Christian Academy in Charlotte.
Reggie Williams was a coach
at a number of high schools
and junior colleges
and community colleges.
He operates his own basketball
academy now I believe out of Bowie
or somewhere in that region.
So it's really interesting to look
at all of the guys who went back
into coaching and wanted to make
an influence on young people
through the sport, because of
what they got from Coach Wade.
Thank you for your question.
>> How you doing?
>> I'm great, how you doing?
>> Pretty good, pretty good.
Just kind of blown away by the
overview, the historical overview.
I grew up in West Baltimore.
>> Okay.
>> And so spent a lot of
time both at Lafayette courts
and Flag as I was growing up.
And I think oftentimes
what's kind of absent
from that East Baltimore story
is that there were so many guys
that were even better than Muggsy
and David Wingate and Reggie
who never even played
high school basketball
because of the failing
educational system in Baltimore.
I'm just interested because I grew
up in Baltimore, you
grew up in Brooklyn.
Wanted to hear you share some
of your impressions
of the neighborhood.
Because most of the sections of East
Baltimore where Dunbar is located,
these neighborhoods
look the same way now
than they did 30 plus years ago,
with a backdrop of having, you know,
Johns Hopkins Hospital in
the center of East Baltimore.
One of the most prolific you know,
health institutions in the country.
Yet, those neighborhoods in East
Baltimore where Muggsy and Wingate
and all them played, these
neighborhoods still look the same,
you know, 30 plus years ago.
So I'm just interested in
hearing your perspective.
>> Okay. I'll touch on the
first part of your question.
I mean, I don't think I'm
credentialed enough to really talk
about the socioeconomic's
and the politics
of why things look
the way they do today.
But you make a very valiant
point, a very valid point.
I loved what you said though
about the great talents
that didn't make it.
Because there are minor characters
in this story that really speak
to why these guys made
a pact with one another,
to hold each other
to a high standard.
And I'll give the example
of the greatest player ever
from the history of Baltimore, as
much as I love Carmelo Anthony,
I'm a long struggling Knicks fan,
Carmelo's going to the Hall of Fame.
As much as Sam Cassell accomplished
winning NBA championships
in the NBA.
The greatest player from
Baltimore is a young man
by the name of Skip Honey Dip Wise.
He was six foot five.
He was every bit the talent of a
Jerry Weston and Oscar Robertson.
But heroine, drugs, and crime
took him off of his path.
Skip got a scholarship to
go to Clemson University
and became the first
freshman in the history
of the Atlantic Coast Conference
to be a first team all-ACC player.
That tells you how good he was.
But his decline was
precipitated by becoming addicted
to narcotics, falling into crime.
Instead of his name appearing on
the back page for his headlines,
his name was on the police blotter,
and on the front pages of the paper,
because of his arrests and the
things that happened to him.
And Muggsy and those guys saw
Skip and said, Skip was better
than everybody, and he fell down,
we can't let that happen to us.
So there is a great lineage of some
miraculous players from Baltimore
that you've never heard of, who were
phenomenal talents, that got caught
up this great plague of drugs.
Thank you for your question.
>> I don't know how far you follow
the key characters after Dunbar.
Bob Wade went on to Maryland and
was not a successful experience.
Do you cover in the book, or can
you talk about what happened there
to take him off the
path that he was on?
>> Well, the book really
focuses on the '81, 1982 season,
and we kind of gloss over '82, '83.
There is a mention of Wade's
experience at Maryland,
but it's really not
an exhaustive look.
And I think, you know, I think it's
time that he kind of told his story
from his perspective on
his experience at Maryland.
And one of the things that
is really unfortunate is,
that because he was not
successful at Maryland,
for people who have a passing
interest, and they hear that name,
they think of Bob Wade, high
school coach, in over his head,
failed at Marilyn, and cheated.
But I think his legacy is so much
bigger than that when you look
at the lives that he impacted,
the hundreds of lives.
There are over 100 kids that
he coached in either football,
basketball, or baseball
at Dunbar that went
on to get athletic
scholarships to college.
And they felt like he was a
father figure to many of them
who didn't have a father
figure in their lives.
So we touch on it a little bit
at the end where we say, hey,
this is where they are now.
But I think that's an
entirely different story.
>> Did he go back to high
school coaching in Baltimore?
>> He actually came
back to Baltimore,
never coached another
game of basketball,
but he became the director
of athletics
for the Baltimore City Public
School Systems and oversaw all
of the athletic programs
for all of the schools
in the public school system.
He just recently retired, and
they had a big ceremony at Dunbar.
A lot of the old players came back.
And they named the court after him.
Thank you for your question.
>> Great presentation.
I'm a Brooklyn guy also.
Hats off to Brooklyn.
[applause].
Have you ever gone back to Brooklyn
and worked with some of the kids
in the community where you lived?
>> I do go back.
My mom is still in the area,
my family is still in the area.
So I try to get back
once every few months.
I live in Maryland now,
but fortunately I'm only a
three-and-a-half-hour drive
and two-and-a-half-hour
ride on the Amtrak.
So I do get back quite often.
And Brooklyn looks a lot
different than it did.
I tell a lot of people now
that say, hey, you know,
I was in your old neighborhood.
I say, yeah, that was dangerous
when I was growing up there.
But I'm happy that mom can
walk around the corner and eat
at a Thai food place and
sit outside with her friends
and not have to dodge stray bullets.
>> What part of Brooklyn
did you grow up in?
>> I grew up in Bedford Stuyvesant.
I lived in Starrett
City, East New York.
Mom is now in Fort
Greene, Clinton Hill area.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi. I haven't read the book
yet, but I was curious to know
if the players, did they play at
AAU basketball during the summer?
And if so, were they
on the same team?
And if you've seen that's
different the way it is now
where sometimes players
are just sort of divided
between their AAU team and
their high school team?
>> That's an excellent question.
And we touch on that in the book,
because the climate is
so much different today.
The AAU structure is dominated
by the sneaker companies,
the apparel companies, and
this large outlay of cash.
So today your prestige is defined
by what team you're playing with.
Oh, I'm on team mellow,
or, you know,
I'm on this team, I'm on that team.
You'll find that there are teams
where the star player is a kid
from Texas or California.
Well, how is this kid playing
on a New York AAU team, right?
Back then, the most powerful person
in high school basketball was not
Nike, not Under Armour, not Adidas.
It was a gentleman by the
name of Howard Garfinkel,
who ran the Five-Star
Basketball Camps.
And so what would happen was, Coach
Wade would put these guys in a van.
They would drive up to
Pennsylvania to participate
in these Five-Star Basketball Camps.
The director of the drills
and the teaching was a guy
by the name of Bobby Knight.
Young coaches who were still
in high school at the time,
begging for a college job, like Dick
Vitale, a number of other coaches,
Rick Pitino, John Calipari.
These guys were high
school coaches who were
up there running drills
and trying to learn.
So picture Bob Wade driving
a van up to Five-Star,
and all of these long limbed
individuals get out the van.
Howard Garfinkel runs up to Wade,
and his nickname for him was sugar.
And he'd say, sugar, I hear
you're keeping all these secrets
down in Baltimore.
And so Howard Garfinkel and
Wade actually almost got
into a physical confrontation.
Because when Muggsy was
at the camp, there were --
he was not a national prospect.
No one knew how good he was.
And so there were a number
of point guards at the camp
that had these national reputations.
So they would have a draft.
And Bob Wade picked, because
of the numbers that got picked
out of a hat, he picked
the worst center.
And in lieu of that, he
was granted the first pick
of the best point guard in the camp.
And he picked Muggsy.
And Howard Garfinkel lost his mind.
He said, sugar, you can't do
that, you can't take this kid,
you got to pick the best guy.
And he says, I did
pick the best guy.
I know he plays for you in
Baltimore, but nobody's heard
of him, he's a midget,
you can't take him.
Wade said, I'm not only taking
him, but he's going to be my horse.
And in Five-Star terminology,
a horse was --
every player had to play
at least half the game,
you could designate
one player as a horse
that could play the whole game.
And that was reserved for guys
like Patrick Ewing,
Ralph Sampson, Len Bias.
No one had a five-foot-three-inch
horse.
So they had to be separated.
And Garfinkel says, you're screwing
up the camp, do what you want to do.
And Wade says, I bet
you I go undefeated
and win the championship
with Muggsy.
And Garfinkel says, you'll
never win a game, it's a bit,
I'll take you to dinner
if you win one game.
Muggsy destroyed every
point guard at that camp.
Tommy Amaker, the great
coach at Harvard now,
who was a phenomenal point
guard at Duke University,
said he saw Muggsy tear
up the top-rated point
guard in the country.
Did not sleep the night before
he had to play against him.
And for the first time in his
career, he was talking to himself
when Muggsy was guarding him,
saying, keep the ball tight,
don't let them steal it,
don't let them embarrass you.
And after that camp, was when
Muggsy became a national phenomenon.
And in Howard Garfinkel's Five-Star
report that he sent out to all
of the top college coaches, he
gave Muggsy a Five-Star rating,
which was the highest rating
you could give, and he only gave
that to elite players that
could dominate in college.
And in the comments section,
he called Muggsy the greatest
peanut since Planters.
It was a different time.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks for your question.
How are we doing on time?
Two minutes left.
I think we got time
for one more question.
>> Don't be shy.
>> One more question.
If you're not near the mic,
stand up and get it in.
[inaudible question].
You know, that's a separate topic.
I mean, to me.
I'm sorry, he said could
I speak about the --
it was just a strictly basketball
question that's kind of off-topic.
Can I speak about the
legacy of Len Bias.
From a basketball perspective, Len
Bias was the greatest player I saw
in the Atlantic Coast Conference.
He was in the same conference at
the same time as Michael Jordan.
And if Len had not passed
away, we might be talking
about Air Bias right now,
because he was that good.
His death and the controversy
really brought the drug culture
that was destroying
America to the forefront
of a national conversation.
It became the hottest topic
in the corridors of Congress.
There was some knee-jerk
reactions and some laws
that were put into place.
Which kind of resulted in low-level
drug offenders receiving longer
sentences than murderers.
You know, there's a very
deep legacy to Len Bias.
But one of the saddest things
for people from this area
who saw how brilliant he was.
And it really made us change
our perception of drugs,
because we thought that it
was just the junkies outside.
And we didn't realize
how prevalent it was.
And we didn't realize that,
if it could touch this
beautiful angelic young man,
who had such a beautiful future
ahead of him, who was gifted
by the basketball gods, in ways
that not many of the people were,
then that was a sign on the highway
that this problem was really,
really, really bigger than we had
anticipated and was going to be kind
of really ugly when we
saw how it manifested.
So I've got to wrap it up.
I really want to thank
everyone for taking the time.
I know Shonda Rhimes is
speaking at the same time.
And I was mad at myself
for speaking at this time,
because I wanted to
go check out Shonda.
But you guys could've been anywhere
today, anywhere at this festival,
and I'm really, really humbled that
you chose to spend a few minutes
with me to learn about this book.
It was a passion project
10 years in the making.
I'm really excited to release it.
It's much bigger than basketball.
And I hope if you do read
it, that it touches you.
I'm not going to sell the basketball
short for basketball junkies.
The basketball action is great,
but there's so much more to it.
So thank you very much.
I really appreciate you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.